[Music]
anyways jake paul fight rematch
i watched three boxing main events this
weekend and the ufc card this weekend
and formula one uh too much sports yeah
big sports weekend big sports weekend uh
so what's what's the deal with this what
the [__] i thought he was fighting tommy
fury and now he pulled out i guess that
dude the way concept kind of worded it
pretty nicely uh tommy fury like over
trained there's this clip over trained
yeah i think he has a broken rib
there's this [__] stupid instagram
story of him and his brother i think
it's ty's i think it was tyson
slamming like a 12-pound medicine ball
into his ribs like while he's laying on
the ground and they're like trying to
condition like getting hit
break your [__] man come on
facebook facebook you went way too hard
so i think it's just like he's
legitimately out like he can't
like he's seriously injured yeah it
would be it'd be
a
[__] huge error why don't they cite
the actual reason why do they just say
it's a medical
reason um it's a good question
boxing is a
weird sport
i actually watched the dude who fought
on the last jake paul fight his name is
montana love it dude is pretty sick with
the hands it's crazy what a good boxing
match looks like everyone i think has
like the jake paul
mayweather fights in mind when you watch
a good boxing match it is really [__]
compelling
it's definitely a chess match this dude
female he got his uh belts taken this
weekend and it was like a big upset he's
been cheesing it up on instagram like so
tough like cringe posting like [__]
about god and like i will come back and
people are like bro just you lost the
laws just take the l it's fine like but
then this article came out that
apparently he had [__] a torn
esophagus
oh and he had air like all compressed in
his system
um how do you tear your esophagus i
don't know like from
lying on the floor on the floor and
someone dropping at 12 pounds yeah
exactly medicine ball right on his
neck this is what it feels like to get
punched in the throat dude you got to be
ready
and i guess the doctor was like oh he
could have died in there and that was a
situation where it seemed like [__]
hubris like he had a diagnosis going in
that was like yo dude you shouldn't do
this the story i got was he was just
like [__] you
and then cost him his belts so wow
um
but i think they don't state why because
maybe it's a strategy thing
yeah they don't want jake knowing for
the actual fight what side of the body
is weaker
i don't know so you think they'll do a
rematch they'll probably schedule it
again but tyron woodley stepped in yeah
so what do you think of that by the same
i mean dude like tyron you know he
hasn't won an mma round in his last five
fights and he had some success with jake
but
uh merry christmas for tyron yeah jesus
christ get pulled up people are saying
yeah millions of dollars here you go
they're saying off the first fight he
made pretty much his entire ufc career
wow and he's about to do that again
pretty much
you can't blame him yeah no i would do
that 100
and like you can see like you know jake
is already setting the stage for them to
be friends after this why he's like
already like you know tyron's only one
man enough to step up and you know like
that whole [__] and i mean to uh
something that we didn't even talk about
the last one that other people brought
up which is fair you know that they're
like jake showed resolve like he took a
[__] heater from tyron yeah he was
standing there yeah
uh but so i don't know i think with
boxing it's unless you're really [__]
good like canelo i think knockouts are
like either very accurate or like jake
paul versus ben askren like a [__]
clear yeah you know
yeah okay they're like disadvantaged
yeah i think anyone's gonna get dropped
i think it's just gonna be some
knockdowns maybe and yeah i'm not gonna
watch it
i'm not watching this one i'm not gonna
do it i'm not gonna stream it i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna do anything i swear don't
don't give me that he said mm-hmm
i'm definitely not gonna use a vpn
in a
private browser
to stream the fight did you see
like the lawsuits that h3 is going
through with that ryan kavanagh guy yeah
and it all started from the first fight
he like played a clip of it on the
podcast weird and he got sued for
damages basically lame bro that's pretty
wild so lame and the article that he
came out with was like yeah because of
like calculating the total number of
damages that h3 caused by like streaming
that one tiny little clip it was like a
million people saw your podcast that's a
million people that's like a million
people that would have bought the show
beforehand so it's 55 million dollars of
revenue that we lost because of you
i guarantee you nobody would have no not
one of those million people would have
bought it no that's why they're watching
it on the [__] thing yeah they're
like i'm not gonna buy this oh yeah
ethan cost you
what would have been
the one of the highest performing
pay-per-views of all time i don't think
so yeah gotta here shout out devin haney
man devin haney had a had a pretty dope
win this weekend as well it's funny
because in mma the judging feels
definitely more consistent in boxing i'm
watching this card on sunday with
jervanta davis i forget to do his first
time his last name is cruz and the chat
as it's getting in the later rounds
they're like oh they're going to rob him
yep they're gonna give it to gervanta
you know
you didn't put on enough of a show and i
was just like on time
devonta davis got it wow people were
like man that was that was a draw at
least you know like but it was kind of
wild
all the three boxing cards that i
watched how like people were saying like
these boxers need to put in enough work
by round like seven eight otherwise it
just seems like a champion or a favorite
can sort of coast yeah in the four
rounds like as long as they're scoring
points and like they're just they're
looking active they're going to win yeah
that's in every sport though that's
every judge sport
yeah yeah i mean i used to happen to
diving all the time yeah i mean even mma
that's how [__] about that but no
in what capacity like like you could be
uh the best diver in the world but if
you're not like the guy that everyone
likes yeah it's like you automatically
get less points because the judges favor
the the dude that's crazy yeah there's
this one guy that was like the joy of
canadian diving oh [__] off yeah and he
was like i don't know it's just like
like an attractive guy
charming everyone it was like a winner
right he won like the olympics i'm
pretty sure and everyone was just
like in love with him and so all the
judges like he could you know be sure
it'd be over and they'd be like nine
you know what but it's a nine yeah yeah
yeah that's a nice like it's crazy just
that
just like the obvious bias and
everyone's just like yep yeah that's why
i think judge sports probably their days
are numbered computers are so powerful
now you know like image analyzing
software and everything is so powerful
that like eventually we'll have you know
cameras on every basketball game like
actually calling fouls and stuff like
that yeah
i mean uh back when
i don't know i don't think i've brought
this up before but me and a buddy like
the first company i worked at like
actually writing code i was like kicking
around this idea of like
using connects to try to like xbox
connects to try to um see if there was a
way to like create a system specifically
for mma to like put out more data like
in real time of like a fight
like and and calculate
obviously connects not that accurate so
this idea was out the window but like
yeah even in the last you know four or
five years the amount of data that you
get from like during an mma match like i
don't think there was they never used to
do like this many punches thrown and now
it's like this is how many head kicks is
so many to the head to the body to the
leg yeah i think it's gonna be crazy
when they can do stuff like oh yeah his
punching speed is this and you know out
of this many jabs this this many fall
short this many connect and
it's gonna get scarier when they can say
like oh yeah like his hook comes from
this angle and you could see fighting
turning into like some weird like
formula one type [__] where it like
becomes like a razor's edge
can't keep you away from that chicken i
mean dude it always comes back to racing
you